welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and as always it's good
to see chewbacca the channel just in
time for a breakdown of the book of boba
fett episode 2 is just dropped on disney
plus and in this video we're going to be
breaking down all the easter eggs and
jar jar blink and you'll miss a moment
that appeared in the new entry full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't had a
chance to check it out then i highly
recommend that you check out now you
will click like and also make sure you
subscribe for the fastest hunk of junk
breakdowns in the galaxy every week
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into book of boba
fett episode 2.
okay so last week we watched flashbacks
of boba as he climbed out of the sarlacc
pit looking like how i did after new
year's eve see it seems it seems a bit
rude that whatever that is spraying on
his face anyway we saw as boba won the
respect of the sand people after he was
taken captive and in the present he was
trying to do the same things with the
crime lords of tatooine baba was
ambushed and he ended up being taken
back to his tank to heal which should
have you fully caught up now one thing
that we didn't point out last week is
how much fat actually changes his
patterns of speech depending on who he's
dealing with he's always kept it
respectful but the guys actually changed
the way he talks to be more dignified
depending on who he's speaking with
though it's not a massive easter egg
it's a nice bit of attention to detail
that's something to bear in mind when
you watch the show
now we once more start outside jabba's
palace with fennec and the prisoner that
she caught last week they bring him in
through the main door which we saw
opening up this way during the beginning
and return of the jedi even though the
whole background is cg you can actually
catch that they added a heat wave to it
which shows just how much attention to
detail that they were putting into
things you might also notice that there
are rancor heads on the throne now which
is something that i didn't catch last
week the prisoner speaks her tease and
says ichuta which you might remember
being a cursed word that was used to
c3po during the empire strikes back
though they don't have a protocol droid
to translate it it's still a pretty well
known curse word like your scruffy
looking nerf herder
sorry i i shouldn't have said that don't
cancel me however what they do have is
88 jabba's torture droid who is voiced
by matt berry hatties is a common tongue
amongst the gangsters as they of course
control the trade on tatooine and later
on we get more of their kind now we
learned that the assassin is part of a
group known as the order of the
nightwind who i don't believe have
popped up in the star wars saga before
let me know if you've heard of them
before of course in the comments but we
discover they're very expensive and
bound by the ancient rule of snitches
gets stitches dropped into the rancor
pit he ends up revealing that it was the
mayor who sent the killers but that kind
of becomes murky in this entry as he
denies doing it now it was thought that
moochie a rancor from the bad batch
could end up appearing in the series at
some point as he was taken in by bib
fortuna but it seems like they don't
want to confuse things for people who
haven't watched that thus the rancor
from return of the jedi is still dead
and they haven't brought in another one
instead now the episode is called tribes
of tatooine and whereas stranger in a
strange land had some significance last
week this entry's name is pretty
straightforward boba and carl go out to
visit the mayor and amongst the people
we catch a group of transoceans which
are the same species as bosque demanding
that the mayor grant him an audience we
get a bit of a bureaucracy joke and his
servant played by david pesquez he steps
in david is part of one of the world's
most famous improv groups that was
documented in the film trust us this is
all made up now he drops a joke about
how boba hasn't been carried in by a
litter which calls back to last week's
entry when he was made fun of for the
same thing here we meet mayor moxhazy
who is an ithorian hythorians are often
referred to as hammerheads and they have
to speak through translated devices
which we can see strapped onto his head
mark is actually played by robert
rodriguez who is of course the director
of the show muk's bodyguards end up
shooting the assassin which shows he's
not messing around and boba takes the
tribute that he should have got last
week mock tells fed to go to gaza's
sanctuary and he returns to the cantina
from last week we can also catch the
droid r3x on a table and you might know
it from the disney star tours right
beside the droid is also mouse like
alien which is known as a chad rafan and
a chad fan is what i call my wife shabao
now furthermore we catch max rebo
busting up those keys it's nice to see
the guys getting steady work after
jabba's sail barge was destroyed gaza
doesn't seem happy to see fed and boba
says she's sweating like a gumter on
mustafar mustafar was the lava planet
that anakin and obi-wan ended up
fighting on a revenge of the sith and it
just asked anakin the place is pretty
hot he's pretty armless though that
anakin hey don't don't drink too much
yeah you might end up legless hey you
haven't haven't that now here she brings
up the twins a pair of huts that have
now laid claim to jabba's throne and we
watch as they're carried in which of
course juxtaposes how phet refuses to be
this is such an awesome introduction and
you can actually see the board they ride
on bending due to their weight i thought
it was pretty messed up that one even
used a little mouse like creature to
wipe down their sweat and this
introduction of course symbolizes how
much they use others at their disposal
there's of course the litter they have
propping them up and even little life
forms like that that have no other
purpose than to basically clean their
body amongst the servants we can also
catch some neat toes and though these
tend to be quite high up in star wars
society one being a slave here shows
just how powerful that the huts are the
neat does later pop up as part of the
swoop by gang which kind of gives a nod
to the power difference here now at this
point we're introduced to a major
character from the expanded law this is
black cross and tan or black k for short
that was a term used by dr aphra and i'm
gonna be using it as well because i'll
constantly keep messing up the
pronunciation of cross and cross suntan
now black k is a male rookie bounty
hunter that was originally taken from
kashyyyk which appeared in revenge of
the sith he was then trained to become a
bounty hunter and he's one of the most
feared in the entire galaxy even without
the reputation that wookies can pull
someone's arm out of their sockets fed
is clearly trying to distance himself
from being a bounty hunter as he makes
it clear to the mayor that he's not
however watching characters like this
show up and the hutt's call him one
pretty much cements that he's still
viewed that way and that'll take a long
time before things change fair tells
them to go back to now hutter which is a
swampy marsh bug planet that the huts
rule due to the environment they're most
comfortable there and it's a bedrock of
criminal activity that uses the word
major dorno to describe bib fortuna and
this is typically used to talk about the
head of a household there's a lot of
ancient phrases used throughout the
series such as daimyo which is a
japanese name for a lord star wars took
a lot of inspiration from old samurai
films i'm glad that they're paying
tribute to stuff like this through the
language used the huts leave but it's
clearly not over and much in the same
way that gangster families work one must
get permission before making an attempt
on their life jump back to barbara and
his back to tank which once more brings
up imagery of luke when he was in one
during the empire strikes back we get a
flashback of fet training with the sam
people and this explains how he ended up
getting their combat techniques which he
applied during the mandalorian and also
the episode last week the tuscans sorry
sand people easily beat him because he
doesn't hold the staff correctly but he
quickly learns their ways as with most
training sequences in the star wars saga
he starts off cocky and arrogant but the
character quickly realizes that this is
in the way now watching boba along with
the sound people are massive and we also
catch a banter which they used to ride
throughout the desert we get more
creatures coming from the sands showing
just how dangerous a tatooine is and
also a train moving through the desert
the panther is taken out first and shout
out simone berman on twitter for
pointing out that this is another
western slash wild west call back people
used to shoot buffaloes from trains for
fun and the banter was shot first on
purpose so that the sand people couldn't
flee some people shooting at a transport
is something that we've also seen in the
saga namely when they attacked the pod
racers in the phantom menace we learned
that this train is transporting spice
and narcotic in the star wars universe
that was based upon spice from the dune
series you can catch a brief glimpse at
one of the people on the train and this
is a member of the pike syndicate these
ruthless gangsters have built their
whole society around it and they've
harvested spice into a drug that they've
used to build a fortune with now shout
outs philip molina from new rock stars
are pointing out that there's a 310 to
huma vibe to this entire entry due to
the train heist plot in the night we
catch the sweet bikes once more which we
saw last week belong to nick toes
writers it is possible that in an
offshoot of this group is arden lin who
you might know from the expanded lore
lane was a master of terrace cassie that
may have been teased in the trailers and
i'd love to see her pop up in the series
at some point though she isn't amongst
the group we see potentially she'll
chase after fed for what he does later
on but we'll talk about that more in
just a bit now the tuscans burn the body
and fett uses sign language to
communicate with the raiders he says
that he will stop the train and he
travels out into the desert to probably
what's the second biggest hive of scum
and villainy that i've ever seen i shout
simon again for pointing out that this
could be toshi station and that the
couple we meet here maybe kami and leis
who showed up in italy at cena during a
new hope i think that's an absolutely
incredibly deep layered easter egg and
it just flashes out the world of
tatooine even more now i love how the
gang's costume are based on a biker gang
and we even catch a crest on one of
their backs lays tries to stand up for
himself but he's hit worse than the
thumbs down button is when i bust out a
pun but luckily fett arrives in time
using the tuscan ways he knocks them off
their fet and yeah the dislike button is
right there you punk i think it really
shows his character when he learned a
new skill and then decided to use it to
take out the first gang of people that
he could find he knows these neat toes
are bad dudes and they might end up
attempting to get revenge later on now
fair ends up taking their suit bikes and
he returns to the sam people bearing
gifts now i kind of think that because
of their alliance that they'll end up
showing up later in the series when
fett's back is really against the wall
with the huts he teaches the people how
to ride a bike and it's actually a
really nice moment stranger in a strange
land was actually about a human that was
raised on mars returning to earth to
learn about our customs but in turn he
also taught us things too though that
was the title of the last episode i
actually think it works really well here
and they plan the train heist everyone
learns to go bike to bike and back to
back in what is a really fun scene that
ends up becoming a master of stick and
they head to the train shot forward by
an engine i think this might actually
belong to a pod racer that's been
retrofitted to propel the train faster
at one point we see the driver messing
around with the display which does look
very similar to how pod racers work it's
not an easy thing to take down and the
pikes once more shoot the panthers first
them showing up in the series could also
link in with kira who we last saw at the
end of solo as the group were part of
that film it is possible that she might
show up to at some point so we can find
out what happened to her whilst the main
trilogy was going on now this is a
really outstanding scene and everyone
who was down on the show last week i
think will have their opinions turned
around by how well the whole thing works
train robberies are of course a staple
of western movies and one also showed up
in solo as well the engine is used as a
weapon but in typical western fashion
the driver ends up breaking it so that
the train can't stop vet manages to do
it though and yeah what a great scene
had a lot of fun with this now the pike
syndicate leader ends up unmasking and
we can see that they're an amphibious
type alien i'm pretty sure that we
haven't seen what these look like before
but let me know below if i'm wrong as i
haven't had time to read every single
star wars graphic novel or watch every
single show i'm sorry i just don't have
that much time that then brings up the
minds of castle which is where spice is
formed from and you might know it from
being the home of the infamous kessel
run now fair tells them that they're
allowed to pass through but only if they
pay a toll which they agree to that then
instructs them to walk in single file
which is something that the tuscans do
to hide their numbers he also tells them
to head to anchor head which was brought
up last week anchor head office passage
of the planet and though fett wanted to
flee there in the previous episode we
see here that he wants them to go
showing that he's made his home they're
given the black melons which fet was
given last week and it's shown as a sign
of respect as moisture is of course very
precious in the desert well it was but
then these lads just sprayed everywhere
so they don't care now the chief brings
up the tribes of tatooine a call back to
the episode title and this talk actually
makes you feel a bit sorry for them the
guys are very limited by technology and
though they're the natives the
off-welders have come in and taken over
lucas very much wore the dune
inspirations on his sleeve and they are
quite similar to the fremen in that
barber also goes on a spice trip
somewhat similar to polar tradies but
whereas he just had it by ingesting it a
lizard also shoots a vet's nose that
night he wanders through the desert
until he sees a tree surrounded by water
i got a lot of camino vibes here and the
branches could potentially represent the
clone brothers that are part of his
family tree there's also red eyes that
surround it and judging by the concept
art and the credits these are jawas now
the branches wrap around him like the
sarlacc pit and we also get flashes of
kamino here we get a young barber
watching his father django leave and i
love these little bits of his childhood
that are dotted throughout the series
it's such a well put together scene and
boba awakens and travels back to the
people with a branch trees of course
would find it difficult to grow in the
desert and this branch is very much a
metaphor for fett who's managed to
survive there too juxtaposing the
clothing part of last week's episode we
get fed this time being dressed like the
sam people and i love how this scene
mirrors the one at jabba's palace with
the droids this is something that the
emperors of old used to have done to
them and it gets him appearing similar
how he did during his first appearance
in the mandalorian he builds his own
tuscan staff out of the branch and this
is something that is mirrored in the
jedi when they build their own
lightsabers it's very much seen as a
coming-of-age moment and it's such a
good way to end the entry showcasing how
far he's come that night they sit around
the fire victorious with fed as part of
their ranks together he and another
member dance and this tribal form of
expression is supposed to show unity
amongst the chaos that ends the episode
and if you've been keeping up with the
news reports around the show then you'll
have seen there was a big rumor that got
a lot of press this week i'm going to be
talking about that in just a bit but i
thought i'd drop my review of the
episode first now last week seemed to
divide people's opinions online but i
thought this one was incredible it's
like its own little standalone film and
it might even be my favorite star wars
disney plus episode thus far really
really well put together and everything
in it worked for me after this one i'm
fully on board with the show and i can't
wait to see what happens next anyway on
to the leaks and these are pretty big
ones so if you don't a major appearance
in the show potentially spoiled then
thanks for sticking with me and i'll see
you on the next one honestly though i
don't know how people do it you know
they hear there's going to be a big
report and die about the video and yeah
i'm just not that strong yet i have the
utmost respect for you if you leave the
video at this point i just want
everything spoiled for me i don't care
anyway it's been reported by several big
news outlets that harrison ford will be
showing up in the book of boba fett
though this is unsubstantiated at the
moment it's appeared in outlets like the
daily mail and the scum i know they're
terrible newspapers terrible it's more
than just your uncle kevin spoilers
telling you that he thinks al pacino is
gonna be in one division now according
to the sun ford will be digitally the
aged much like how mark hamill was
during the mandalorian they stated that
sources have told them that he spent
three days filming in london for a cameo
scene solo and fett of course last saw
each other as he missed a magooed his
jetpack and sent him hurtling into the
mouth of the sarlacc also yeah a lot of
you punks last week you tried correcting
me on something that you [ __ ] got wrong
i said that the stormtrooper might have
come from a new hull but some of you
guys are like actually the stormtrooper
fell in just before boba fett did but
listen you punks there were no
stormtroopers with jabba just annoyed me
how many people were saying it
especially with there being already
enough genuine mistakes in these videos
as it is anyway that's a pretty big
reveal about harrison ford and one of
the big things about the mandalorian is
that the luke skywalker cameo didn't
leak so i can imagine that this will be
a bit of a blow as it would have been so
cool to see the show unspoiled kind of
feel a bit bad telling you it now if i'm
being honest but you know leaks like
this should always be taken with a grain
of salt and it is possible that he was
there shooting for something else or
just having a holiday obviously let me
know below what you think and i'd of
course love to hear your thoughts on the
episode so make sure you leave them
below we are running competition right
now and giving away three copies of an
mcu boxer of your choice on the 30th of
january and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now said that
to you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of last week or cobra kai
which will be linked on screen right now
we pointed out all the easter eggs in
that series and it's one of our best
videos i promise you so definitely go
check it out right after this if not
then thanks for sitting through this one
i've been paul you've been the best and
i'll see you next time take care peace